hey youtubers it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see Star Wars
Episode seven by now but there's a whole
bunch of stuff happening around episodes
8 and 9 we actually know a little bit
about what's gonna be going on because
ryan johnson and colin trevorrow the guy
who's directing episode 9 have already
started to tease some stuff some of this
will sound familiar is the way they plot
the movies through 8 and 9 and it plays
into some of the Ray theories now just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
episode 7 yet I'm also gonna be
referencing some things from the flash
season 2 with respect to Wally West that
series just has some baby daddy drama
going on just like there is with Ray and
the Star Wars franchise so the Wally
West character is kind of like the Ray
character in that they come from broken
family situations so first big thank
John boyega confirmed that episode 8
totally gonna be darker than episode 7
just like Empire sounds very familiar a
little bit more exciting new locations
but it's not like they're gonna take the
Falcon to a car wash everything is still
gonna look like the Star Wars universe
it's just that we're gonna be going to
different places the cinematography is
gonna be different but it'll still be
hardcore Star Wars all of you that had
complaints about episode 7 mirroring too
many story beats from a new hope and
Empire Strikes Back it seems like
episode 8 is going to address all those
now obviously it's the middle film and a
trilogy so I'm still kind of expecting
it to stay within Joseph Campbell heroes
journey so there'll be certain things
that might seem familiar but I don't
think it'll overtly pay homage to
specific sequences from the previous
films in the way that episode 7 did the
narrative is still very much classic
hero's journey I don't expect it to
deviate from that but just like my Yoda
Luke Skywalker picture here I totally
expect Luke to become the Yoda character
but more like obi-wan in a Yoda context
as he was an empire for Luke Skywalker
seeking a great warrior ru Wars make not
one great so Q the rocky training
montage and the same thing for kylo Ren
with the Knights of Ren
I think that'll actually be really
exciting we haven't seen a whole lot of
sith training outside of the expanded
material we saw during the Clone Wars
you did see a little bit of that but
it's not like we ever got to see Darth
Vader training in his sift powers that's
actually if he had been reading the Star
Wars comics they really get into that
what Darth Vader did like when he
learned that Luke Skywalker was his son
how he pursued him across the galaxy so
if you didn't know that there's actually
a really interesting recent addition to
the canon darth vader learned Luke
Skywalker was his son before Empire
straw
expect before that movie picked up so in
that same vein Luke Skywalker knows
exactly who Rey is but Colin Trevorrow
said that we probably aren't going to
find that out we don't get the big
answer till episode 9 which is a big
deviation from the original trilogy if
episode 8 we're following Empire beat
for beat then we totally learn who her
father was at the very end and it'd be
some crazy twist it be like Supreme
Leader Snoke I am your father
I'll say there are a lot of great
theories out there the two that I am
most open to is that she is somehow
descended from obi-wan and more likely
that she is Luke Skywalker's daughter I
know a lot I've seen a recent theory too
about her name but her full name that I
think is really good I don't necessarily
think it's true but I think it's pretty
cool a lot of people want her full name
to be Kira Rey Skywalker so that her
name would literally be king of light
Skywalker the name Rey translates to
king so already she would be king
Skywalker which i think is pretty cool
on the other side of that been named
after obi-wan Kenobi so just as poignant
but in a slightly different way just
invoking classic Ben Kenobi the real
twist of Episode eight I think is gonna
be rate challenged by the dark side that
was one of Luke's big tests of Empire
Strikes Back did he choose the easy path
and go with his father he could have
said yes instead of screaming and
falling down the shaft like I said
though I don't I don't think it's gonna
be a beep for beat repeat of Empire
Strikes Back so ray will be tempted in
some way in some slightly different
fashion and will have to overcome that
what about Finn and all the other
characters there's also some other
characters that they're casting some big
female roles too so they're they're not
just bringing back the characters from
Episode seven they're bringing in a
bunch of new big ones to finlay a podium
Aaron all those resistance characters
will continue to fight the first order
but just like Empire separated the
characters I think that Rey is going to
be separated from Finn and Poe Dameron
for a while too but I do think of them
as the new Trinity moving into Episode
nine territory though Colin Trevorrow
had had a bunch of quotes so I'm just
gonna read this first one about Ray
we're going to make sure that the answer
the answer of her parentage is deeply
and profoundly satisfying Ray's a
character that is important in this
universe not just in the context of the
force awakens but in the entire galaxy
she deserves it we'll make sure that
that answer is something that feels like
it was something that happened a long
time ago far away and we're not just
telling you what happened so the thought
is if Ray is important in a galactic
context in the way that Luke Skywalker
is important she might cross over into
another trilogy just in the way Luke
Skywalker went from the original trilogy
to this new trilogy so Rey might be
connective tissue with a lot of other
stories that they'll spin out after
episode 9 but that's really just the
surface I think a lot of it will have to
do with the way we understand the force
in the way it binds the Galaxy together
the cosmic force so what they're teasing
is is that the answer to who ray really
is is going to fundamentally change the
way you understand Star Wars which i
think is really awesome but it is a hard
target to hit it is not like bullseye
womp rats in a t16 everybody just
breathes a sigh of relief and remember
that this movie isn't going to come out
for a long time episode 8 is still a
year and a half away and then another
two years after that for episode 9 so
they have a long time to finish this
they don't have to decide how they're
gonna answer that question for a long
time but I bet dollars to donuts that JJ
Abrams Kathleen Kennedy like all the
people in charge of Star Wars at the
beginning had a pitch for Rey even if
they hadn't completely figured it out
they had a loose idea so I want to look
at the notes from that initial Rey pitch
meeting by the time we see episode 9 and
see how much change from their initial
pitch because a lot of times they'll
start with an idea and then six years
later it'll change a lot and I laugh a
little bit but you guys may have heard
about the petition to remove Colin
Trevorrow from episode 9 as director and
replace him with George Lucas bring
George Lucas back there are petitions to
bring George back how do you react to
those petition uh you know I was it was
funny I saw that I think it was
yesterday and it was on a day where I
was at Lucasfilm giving this big speech
to everyone about how we want to channel
the the invention and it's the raw
creativity and then the boldness that
George brought to these films and that's
something that I'm so focused on and not
being afraid that we're gonna embarrass
ourselves by doing something that might
be crazy because when George Lucas made
Star Wars a lot of people thought it was
crazy
but it's the greatest story ever told I
hadn't laughed that hard in a while I
feel like people feel like the
change.org petitions do something
generally they're not very effective so
I wouldn't recommend wasting a lot of
energy on that
the people behind Star Wars will only
fire the director if they feel like he
can't fulfill his initial promise
because he had to pitch them his idea
for episode 9 before they ever hired him
and even on top of that Rian Johnson the
guy who's directing episode 8 wrote
episode 8 & 9 and it's not like Colin
Trevorrow is writing episode 9 so even
if you hate him as a director don't
worry there are a lot of other people it
is gonna take so many people doing so
many bad things for episode 9 to fail
worst case scenario I feel like what's
gonna end up happening after episode 9
has done is people who would be like
well it's not quite as good as episode
day it'll be just like we're turning the
Jedi yeah it's not quite as good as
Empire or Return of the Jedi it's still
a really good film so I think episode 9
will be just fine I don't think there's
anything to worry about
especially now especially this far away
but I just I love the idea that Rey is
going to change our fundamental
understanding of the force in the Star
Wars universe that is such a Babe Ruth
homerun shot to call so let me know in
the comments what do you guys think that
Rey is going to change about our
understanding of the force do you think
it's gonna be kind of like Jason solo
where he gains the ability to harness
the unifying force where it becomes like
this super Jedi that's kind of where I
think they're headed with it where you
know where she's able to ascend to this
higher level of being I explained a
little bit about force ghosts and force
spirits in my last Star Wars video so
I'll put a link in the description they
kind of explained that during the Clone
Wars The Lost missions if you haven't
seen them check it out in it Yoda learns
how to make force ghost and then
obviously after episode 3 he teaches
obi-wan Kenobi how to become a force
ghost and the other big news that I
almost forgot to mention is the Han Solo
movie they're casting a young Han Solo
they've got it down to I think less than
12 actors now none of them seem
particularly exciting to me so I'm just
gonna wait and see until they whittle it
down it's gonna take a couple more weeks
before they find one but they'll totally
announce it in the reason why they're
doing this so soon because the spin-off
Han Solo film isn't gonna happen for a
couple more years is because they think
the person is going to cameo during
rogue one the thought is is that it's
going to be a Spider Man Captain America
Civil War situation you know maybe in a
much more minor way young Han Solo
showing up in a cameo in Star Wars rogue
one
it's just a rumor right now but if they
announce anything I'll totally do a
video for it don't forget that Star Wars
rogue one is coming out this Christmas
we're getting Star Wars every single
year
the rest of time so why you guys wait
for my next video you can click here for
all my Star Wars Easter egg videos you
know you can click here for the Deadpool
trailer I posted earlier today thank you
so much for watching everybody high five
I'll see you guys tonight